a Nigerian student currently studying in
Ontario I assume that means Ontario
Canada Victor is that correct
yes
I'm in California in the San Francisco
Bay Area the the uh near Los Angeles
there's another city called Ontario so
sometimes we have to clarify that
uh and
Detroit cool
meat is uh here
and he will be taking us through
this discussion about AIML careers and
about the program from Purdue
I'll introduce him in just a moment once
we get started we have about 30 more
seconds
Daryl from Colorado cool
I was just in Colorado a couple months
ago because my daughter got her PhD from
uh UC
see you I suppose it's it is in Colorado
all right
we're close enough
I am going to
bring up our
official presentation
and I apologize if I turn from one side
to the other during our
webinar but I do have two systems up
here so
I'll be looking at my other screen from
time to time and I want to welcome
everyone to our program uh preview for
the AIML program from Purdue University
we're going to discuss how this program
can transform your career especially
now that we're in the the era of
generative AI
very exciting time
um mentioned I've got
here and
well
we'll introduce them in a moment
from ground rules for the
webinar please put your questions in the
Q a box that will help me keep track of
them
see we have a visitor from the Czech
Republic very cool
um this session is being recorded we'll
send you a follow-up email
with a link to the recording and
information about claiming the bonus
offer that we're going to discuss
if you want a proof of attendance for
attending this webinar when you exit you
will go into a survey and you have a
place to put your name so that get it
correct on the certificate
so if you want a certificate for
attending this webinar
please fill out that follows on survey
and I'm going to start
get things rolling with a question for
you and the audience
this question is very simple how much
experience do you have are you still
studying for your degree
are you in the workforce so for how long
I'm just going to leave this open for
another 10 seconds because it's a pretty
straightforward question
yeah
I'm going to close this in three two one
you can see about a third of our
audience are people who are still in
school
half of our audience though are people
who have more than five years of
experience so
people I assume you're going to be
looking for a potential career pivot
into Ai and ml so
that's very cool and we're going to stop
uh let's show you how to get that
underway through this program
so
let's talk about what we're going to
cover in the
webinar we're going to as you see we'll
be asking a couple of questions about
you along the way we'll discuss Ai and
ml careers
because how this program prepares you
for those careers and we'll show you
some of the learner outcomes people have
achieved
would go about enrollment steps as I
mentioned whether it will be a bonus
offer that we'll mention later in this
webinar and be a live q a with uh
what's up
oops
talk about uh simply learning just for a
moment before we get going simply learn
the number one online boot camp in the
world for digital skills for the digital
economy and we've helped over 5 million
professionals worldwide and 150
countries to upscale in digital skills
um we've been doing it for 13 years we
deliver our programs fully online so
they're accessible
anywhere that you have a web browser
we're very pleased that the successes
we've helped people achieve in advancing
their careers so
with that I'd like to introduce Amit in
fact I'm going to let him describe his
own experience and background but
welcome Ami thank you
thanks Stuart
so
you've got more than 15 years of
experience how what is the actual number
at this point
uh actually 2016 exactly okay cool
happy anniversary
thank you
so uh just to give you a brief on my
myself uh I'm a statistician and uh then
I did my mbn it and overall I have more
than 15 years of experience in
developing an article and and
statistical solution and off later I
have been utilizing machine learning and
deep learning Concepts to build solution
for for different sets of client that I
have I run a small company called
intellectica here which creates data
driven solution for different clients
that we have uh parallely I'm I'm also
delivering corporate training programs
in association with simply learn I'm
doing their program uh with the Purdue
University as well as Caltech University
so I take care of machine learning deep
learning uh statistical analysis using
python or SAS or Excel for that matter
any other tool which is which is
required to be done and overall I have
more than now that has to be updated to
it I have more than 4500 hours of
experience now in terms of delivering
lecture and uh clientele if you talk
about I have more than 150 clients where
I have delivered training program I've
been doing this since last uh 12 years
these corporate training programs so
that in a nutshell what I have been
doing
thank you very much I will update that
for future sessions 4 500 is impressive
um and
we're going to talk about uh careers in
Ai and machine learning and you've
you've built a career in Ai and machine
learning so
the audience is very interested I think
in hearing
from you what your career Journey has
been like
um let's kind of set the stage for that
um so
this is
would you agree with this statement that
Ai and machine learning are a way to
extend human capabilities
yeah and that person with this
particular statement if you see the
variety of applications that we have
been using which is driven by AI is
actually enhancing the entire uh uh
experience and including the human
capabilities there are a lot of stuff
that that we are able to uh do in a very
efficient manner because of these
capabilities that we are enjoying at the
moment you talk about uh Google photos
you talked about uh chat GPT and all it
has taken our our cap it has actually
enhanced our capability to a different
level altogether
so
we have people who worry about
AI replacing them and work um
the reason that AI is so important these
days is
we're flooded with data especially since
the pandemic where so much of our Lives
moved to the digital domain even as that
process was going on for the previous
several decades it really accelerated in
the last several years didn't it
actually and uh
a lot of data to process you talk about
any business these days they focus a lot
in terms of capturing data the idea is
to once you have that data you can
analyze in an automated fashion and then
build certain strategy on top of it and
that's where machine learning and and
deep learning algorithms come to the
rescue in terms of handling vast amount
of data and it doesn't matter whether
it's a structure data or unstructured it
can analyze both about types of data and
then build certain uh insights for you
which you can convert into actionable
for a particular business so that's why
it's pretty important
yeah and uh the reason we emphasize data
here is that
you know in
times past the rate of transactions and
the interactions with the customers or
your interactions with uh with
businesses or a slower Pace
um there were it was possible
uh to use paper record keeping for a lot
of businesses and then digital record
keeping but it was still a matter of uh
something that was a kind of a tractable
problem for
the management to solve to take a look
at what data was available and
develop plans and insights from that
today the amount of data is
too big and it's coming in too quickly
for that so you have to rely on
automated systems to
handled that not only record keeping but
also analysis and insight the derivation
right
that's correct actually and uh if you
look at concept wise we had certain
analytical Concepts since ages but
because of a lack of data and lack of
technology to add to that in terms of
analyzing uh in in fast manner we
couldn't succeed earlier but now in last
decade or so if you see the technology
has gone to a different level in terms
of not only storing the data but also we
have capability of analyzing vast amount
of data in no time so if you see Ai and
ml it has been uh uh expediated by the
by the technology and that's what has
has brought so many applications as well
yeah
um
so this is a way for people to keep up
with this flow not just it's not a
matter of replacing people it's a matter
of as we said extending their
capabilities to be able to keep up with
the pace of things going so
um can you give us a little bit of
background as we as we look at the
different kinds of career paths that are
available how did you
originally get into the field and
progress through it
so I started as a data analyst so more
on a data engineering side in a sense
that a lot of data was capped getting
captured and I joined a bank for that
matter and Bank introduced the CRM at
that point in time and CRM was supposed
to capture a lot of data points and
which which needed to be analyzed so
iPhone is a data analyst doing some
basic data analysis but with basically
building some data Pipeline and that
kind of uh took me to being an
instructor student I had a very keen
interest in data analysis so once I got
into Data engineering part building data
Pipeline and all I had a very natural
progression toward machine learning uh
part as well or probably building a
end-to-end solution so uh I started as a
data analyst creating certain basic
reports for the management and then
gradually moving to building some
simpler
applications we built recommendation
engine using clustering that point in
time it was way back in in
20078 I'm talking about and then
gradually a machine learning algorithms
became quite uh
uh
in in demand in a sense of adaptability
to to the different industry and and
also the technology was backing Us in
terms of trying different uh and then
doing some experiment with the data so
started moving towards machine learning
deep learning algorithms started
building them and then uh gradually
because I had a statistical background I
started doing some statistical part as
well on top of it and eventually moved
to entirely a data scientist role so if
I have to just brush up on the part that
I have covered in my my professional
Journey so started as a data analyst and
now I work as a data scientist in
between I have gone to different uh uh
phases in terms of machine learning
engineering you can say or you can say
starting with the data engineer
and sometimes probably in terms of
building uh architecture over end-to-end
solution as well okay so you've covered
pretty much the the entire set of roles
here in your personal career and this is
an illustration of how people can begin
at one of these points and move you know
laterally or vertically into the other
points and we look at data science
as being kind of the the overall
category that encompasses
um data analytics but also machine
learning and artificial intelligence
correct
sorry I lost it in between oh I'm sorry
um data science
um
kind of the overall category so is you
describe yourself as a data scientist
and that encompasses the machine
learning and artificial intelligence
right kind of yes but there's a very
fine line there's no set boundaries
these days but uh yes data science is
kind of umbrella term we use these days
for uh which which encompasses your
machine learning AI as well but
sometimes uh if you talk about some
people say that data science and an
artificial intelligence two different
ecosystem all together with some overlap
but nowadays it has become a a generic
term where it it takes care of machine
learning deep learning and everything
that what you're saying is correct
okay
um so this program talks about machine
learning
when someone is enters the field from
that direction are they going to start
as a machine learning engineer developer
or what are the things
through honestly you will have a choice
for that in a sense that machine
learning engineering and and data
scientists if you talk about uh within
the framework of of this entire AIML
data science has it has two different
path altogether these days because of
the uh so much of requirement ml Ops has
also come into the picture but starting
point is same in a sense that you have
to have a basic understanding of how
data is moving in the ecosystem what
kind of analysis you can do how machine
learning algorithm they work what kind
of Statistics is required in terms of
developing certain models so a starting
point will remain same whether you want
to pursue your career uh in in towards
machine learning engineering you talk
about or AI architect or even for that
matter data scientist starting point
will remain same you need a good good
solid foundation uh for for
understanding these terms and then as
you move along you will have uh
understanding that probably uh ml
engineering gives you a more uh uh it
looks very interesting to you or
probably you want to be become a data
scientist so that's how it goes in
general okay great we had a question in
the chat about uh what skills you felt
you lacked at the beginning of your
career or what are the skills that
you've gained along the way to get to
where you are
a pretty good question actually so I
would say initially uh I led towards the
programming part because I was totally
into statistics I understood the
concepts pretty well when it came to any
kind of statistical modeling but
programming was something which was uh
uh uh we were not taught at the at the
college level or university level in
terms of that okay there is a there is a
statistical model you can build with
some of the tools or even if it was
taught it was very uh earlier we used to
you have SPSS and all which has some
limitations in terms of that so I I
would say for my personal Journey uh
programming was something that I had to
pick up and then it's a it's a ongoing
learning process every other month every
other day something new comes up you
have to pick up that you have to
understand how it works and probably
have to start using it so then on the LA
on the uh on the job started learning
other other aspects of machine learning
implementation and then some new
algorithms coming up probably NLP if you
see in last three four years so many new
things have come up so it's an ongoing
Journey but yes programming was
something which I lacked which I picked
up over the period of time okay we had a
question about uh
if somebody lacked mathematical aptitude
if they were if they felt they were a
bit weak in mathematics
could they strengthen themselves and how
much mathematics would they need to have
to to enter this field
honestly telling you mathematics is
important because most of the algorithms
are mathematical optimization algorithms
so I wouldn't deny that but having said
it I'll tell you that
mathematics that we use wouldn't be that
difficult to understand and the kind of
sessions that we have designed uh it
takes care of the basic mathematics that
you talk about which is required in the
machine learning and while teaching also
we explain we give the mathematical
intuition we do not want you to start
probably solving a differential equation
but we give you a mathematical intuition
that this is what is happening so very
intuitive approach so even if you lack
in terms of certain concept of how
exactly you have to solve manually that
wouldn't be a problem but little bit of
mathematics is required which will I
would say inclination towards
mathematics is important to understand
these Concepts okay
appreciate that and
so you need to develop a skill set to be
successful in this field
and that kind of breaks down into some
foundational skills
understanding machine learning methods
and then moving into more advanced
topics so can you take us kind of
through this hierarchy
yeah so the foundational skills which
are mentioned over here is kind of the
uh this is this is a this is a starting
point for you so statistics and map
basics of Statistics uh what is
statistics all about what kind of
analysis you can do within that
particular framework and also you need
to map how these statistical concept
will be useful in terms of solving some
real-time problem they might some of
them might not be used directly but they
might work as a building block for a for
a more com complex and and sophisticated
analysis so for that statistics and
maths is required and then what happens
these analysis that you're gonna learn
later they require a lot of computation
uh and and they they are required to be
done in Faster manner that's where
python it's libraries come as a helping
hand I I look at python as a calculator
for for me which is gonna perform all
the calculations which later on machine
learning and deep learning algorithm
will introduce us to so that's how I
look at it I don't look at it as a
programming platform and and some of us
probably I do not have programming
background and we start thinking we have
to Learn Python N2 and it doesn't happen
that way you need to understand python
how it works and then you have to kind
of cherry pick up those aspects of
python which is required for machine
learning and deep learning so think of
think that way and that's your
foundations foundational skills which
needs to be uh completed needs to be
done and then you move towards learning
methods so there are different learning
methods within the machine learning
algorithms you have supervised you have
unsupervised semi-supervised
reinforcement learning so these methods
which are mentioned over here these
methods will have Within These each
framework will have a number of
algorithms these algorithms are designed
to solve some real-time problems and uh
overall uh the outline will remain same
that you are solving a particular
problem you might choose one approach to
or to another but over overall the
underlying problem objective will remain
same but you need to learn these
algorithms so uh supervised unsupervised
all this you have to learn entirely it
will also consist of your Ensemble
learning that's an example given over
here which is a type of supervised
learning algorithm and then you might
also get into recommendation system
because that's something which is very
important these days when you purchase
something on Amazon it says people who
bought this also purchased some some of
the items that's something every
e-commerce company wants to build or it
could be a streaming platform who wants
to recommend certain showcase and series
to their end users so those are the
learning methods which are there which
you need to pick up at machine learning
level and again it will be dealt with
using python and once you pick up these
algorithms then you can move to the
advanced topics like deep learning where
you deal with the neural networks which
is trying to imitate or simulate human
brain so it tries to simulate the uh uh
human intelligence into machines that's
what neural networks does so that's
where that's probably that will be part
of your deep learning then there you
you'll be introduced with the or you
should learn about a python framework
called Keras and tensorflow a pretty
good framework to implement deep
learning algorithms and within that
framework of deep learning lot of
advancements have happened in in last
few years uh generative uh adversarial
Network or or in general generative
algorithms have been Talk of the Town
these days uh you talk about the fake
you talk about aging app you talk about
uh neural transfer lot of stuff is
happening in the advanced uh in the in
the Deep learning framework so those
topics will pick up you'll also pick up
computer vision how to work with the
images NLP and all so this is uh this is
how you you should move your uh learning
part it means as per this learning path
start with the foundational skills and
then gradually move towards Advanced
topics
great thank you
so let's take a moment for another
question for the audience this one uh
is based on the assumption that you're
all here to learn about careers and
getting qualified for careers in Ai and
ML and if you've looked at other
programs why haven't you started with
one of those yet what was the thing that
was lacking that
you felt you needed to have to be
successful
you can answer more than one
answers in your poll here
uh give you an extra 15 seconds to
answer this
are you looking for a comprehensive
curriculum did you feel you wouldn't get
the Practical examples experience
is it because of the learning style or
is it because of the schedule
I'm going to close the poll in three two
one
share the result with you
and the leading concerns that people in
our audience that they have are finding
a program that's comprehensive that kind
of covers all the skills that just
discussed
funding a program that will give you
practical examples that you can
demonstrate your skills show off
The Experience you've had in
program and then
finding a program that fits your work
schedules
most
concerning so
with that I'm gonna
go into
a moment
so let's talk about this particular
program which is a postgraduate program
machine learning from Purdue University
includes modules from IBM delivered by
simply learn
and it is a program that's fully online
it takes 11 months but you need to only
devote about 10 hours a week or so to
the program you'll have live virtual
classes those are usually weekend
classes or the evening classes too in
this program
those would be weekend classes four
hours on Saturday and four hours on
Sunday
and those are where the Learners
interact with the you or other
instructors directly
go through the topics and then the the
actual examples of how to implement
those
and that's how it goes it will be a live
virtual class where the instructor would
be there they will help them in terms of
understanding a concept then an exercise
and then Implement on a real-time data
where you will understand how to
implement on a given problem so that's
how it goes yeah
and the learning platform not only gives
you access to the live classroom
environment but it also includes the
live virtual machines that you're using
the data sources you're using for the
exercises so you don't have to buy or
create a separate system for practicing
these things it's all included in that
that same platform
um
your platforms available to you 24x7
which means that in between classes you
have uh anytime that you're available
you can do your uh homework your
exercises watch your Preparatory
materials or read books all the things
that you would do to prepare for next
week's class
and you can even do some of that on your
mobile or tablet right
that's correct you can access that on on
your tablet and your mobile and best
thing is you also get the recording for
the session so in case if you missed
something it's already there you can
watch it
yeah and if you if you went to the class
didn't quite catch a particular thing or
you or you want to re-watch the
explanation from the instructor you can
recordings for that purpose too
um and it's a comprehensive curriculum
that Purdue designed this curriculum
around an industry aligned learning path
meaning that they they listen to the
companies that come to them and say this
is what we need
or people were hiring into this role so
this is how the the curriculum was
designed
and
the end of this process you receive your
certificate which is jointly issued by
Purdue and simply learn
um that certifies that you've completed
all the core courses
done them to the satisfaction of Purdue
University
and that includes a Capstone project
along the way you'll be doing a couple
dozen projects that will each produce
artifacts examples that you put in your
portfolio and that culminates in the
Capstone at the end of the of the
program where you do an end-to-end
solution of an industry aligned problem
and um you're you have the option of
taking master classes from Purdue
instructors but also from industry
experts they bring in and some of the
classes will also issue you an IBM
certificate because
those classes are delivered by IBM to
their standards as well so that's an
additional benefit for the for the
program right I mean
that's correct so you get to uh you get
to learn not only from the instructor
who already experienced you also get to
learn from some in some index industry
experts in terms of what are what are
their uh day-to-day challenges how do
they overcome that what kind of issues
they face when you are working on a on a
particular uh uh case study or probably
a particular project so that actually
adds a lot of value thank you um
we also include a career assist program
from Simply learned that extends after
you earn your certificate and I'll
describe that more in a bit
um so Purdue University is if you're not
familiar with it if you happen outside
the United States or North America and
you may not be as familiar with it as we
are here it is one of the top
universities in the United States it's
certainly one of the top public
universities run by the state of Indiana
it's been around for 150 years it has a
very strong engineering background in
fact the the
the company or the University's sports
teams have the nickname the Boilermakers
because when this was founded metal
metal working and building
steam engines and that type of thing was
a big focus of the university and
they've kept up with that engineering
Heritage all along so there's a number
of people who have earned various awards
for their work at unit Purdue uh
including Nobel prizes and so
we're very proud to be associated with
them they're
um
you know we're very honored we're very
honored to have them choose us as the
delivery partner for this program so
uh we know that if you have that name on
your resume your CV it's going to be
um something that people will recognize
worldwide
so uh I mean can we talk about
um
we talked touched on it earlier you need
to have some background in math and
programming
um some background
to seed in this program I'm looking at
this this should not say high school
diploma it is a postgraduate program you
do need to have a bachelor's degree 50
marks for this so I should
make sure that you all understand that
but what kind of background math and
programming can you remind us
should people have
so it consists of in terms of you I have
to mention some mathematical uh content
and it consists of some some vector
algebra and differential calculus but uh
what we do generally is we take care of
those Concepts how it is getting
implemented in machine learning
algorithms so so that's what we do but
uh some background will help you in
terms of catching up with with those
Concepts quickly and uh then then you'll
be able to uh
uh pick up those those algorithms in a
faster manner programming is required
because eventually we want to implement
all these Concepts that you are learning
onto the data which requires a huge
amount of calculations computations
which is very exhaustive so that's where
programs will come into the picture
which will actually uh do the work for
you so that's required so so think that
way that it's a helping hand programming
when it comes to machine learning so
those two aspects if some background if
you are having that will be very useful
beneficial and having said that again I
want to iterate here that a program that
we have designed that has been designed
here is basically takes care of these
Concepts from the from from where you
scratch but still some background will
be very helpful
okay and when we talk about the
necessity for
um
experience
what kind of uh benefit you get from
having work experience when you come
into this program
the work experience uh if you if you
have it helps you in terms of
understanding like how a project moves
generally and just like any other
project machine learning projects also
move into into a business but uh
but apart from that if you are not
having a background into data analytics
or machine learning then it wouldn't be
very useful in terms of uh getting uh
all the knowledge that you are supposed
to have and that that you want to when
you want to work in this particular
domain so that's how it would be
yeah so understanding
how this type of Technology
might be applied in business is a good
background to have so again it's not
mandatory but we do it uh recommend that
you have some work experience
involved in that
um
let's move on to talk about the program
itself
we've
worked with Purdue to create this kind
of
ladder to success a staircase to success
starting with the induction session
which is an online session that teaches
you how to use the platform itself
teaches you where to find your classes
how to register for them how to attend
them online where all the other
resources are that's available to you
gives you an overview of what you're
going to be learning in the program so
once people have taken that induction
session can you kind of take them
through this sequence and
yeah briefly what they're learning
sure so once you have Financial
induction uh we want you to start with
the foundation done so basically python
for data science takes care of the uh
programming part in Python which is
required for data science so from data
science perspective there are certain
libraries which you should be aware of
how how to use them uh what's the
purpose of them and and then how does it
work in real time scenario that those
are the aspects will be covered in
Python for data science so the idea is
that we make you ready for for machine
learning algorithms using python by
introducing you to the different
libraries different Frameworks within
python which will be useful for for all
these algorithms this is what we are
doing and once that part is done then we
move to apply data science with python
so now uh you have already understood
what's python how does it work and how
you're gonna utilize in this entire
program or even going forward important
in real time scenario then comes applied
data science which talks about certain
Concepts within data science framework
which is very important before you apply
a machine learning algorithm so it will
take care of certain data pre-processing
that you are supposed to do or data
cleaning that we do in terms of making
sure that data is of highest quality and
and data Integrity is maintained or
probably sometimes you just transform
data from one format to another so that
the machine learning algorithm can pick
that up and unders and and and take that
understand it and then understand the
pattern come up with the final outcome
so for that matter you need to
understand
a certain courses which is covered in
applied data science with python then we
move to machine learning algorithms so
this is where we start dealing with the
algorithm so we introduce you to
different kind of learning and here
you'll be taught supervised learning
unsupervised learning how do they work
and within each framework you will have
a set of algorithms that that you should
know so we teach you the algorithms and
generally this is taught in this fashion
uh we introduce you to a to an algorithm
we tell you what they are capable of
then we explain you the concept behind
it we give you a mathematical intuition
how it works then we take a case study
and while solving the case study we also
introduced you to to the challenges that
you will face once you are using that
particular algorithm and uh we we
implement the entire uh algorithm using
python so you get the entire Hands-On
understanding that how you're gonna take
a particular problem solve it using an
algorithm that we have taught you and
then also conclude in terms of
understanding whether it's working well
or not so each algorithm will be taught
in the same fashion so that you get
entire understanding how it works and
you are able to implement it also so
that gives a lot of confidence in a
real-time scenario also that how you're
gonna take a a problem and solve it so
that's our machine learning which will
as I mentioned which will take care of
your supervised run supervised learning
algorithms then we'll move to deep
learning with Keras and tensorflow So
within machine learning uh
system you have deep learning algorithms
which consist of your neural network now
these neural networks are are capable of
solving some really complex problems and
we Implement that using Keras and
tensorflow which is a python framework
which is a very user friendly framework
the makes your job much simpler and
easier so deep learning will consist of
building neural networks uh working with
the images in terms of image
classification object detection that you
want to do eventually so how do we work
with the images or it could be some
sequential data in terms of speech in
terms of some time series data that you
want to understand and build a model on
top of it to forecast certain values so
that's what will be taught under deep
learning so again within deep learning
also you will have supervised and
unsupervised learning both will be
covered but this will be majorly
focusing on neural networks
then once that part is covered you will
move to Advanced deep learning and
computer vision which focuses on a
recent advancement in deep learning so
it will consist of uh generative
algorithms like Gans which is uh which
is basically your generative adversarial
Network your Auto encoders in terms of
variational autoencoders and all which
which is which works as a as a
generative algorithm so you'll be able
to generate new images which probably
you have never seen also and then you
will be also taught how to utilize some
more algorithm like it could be a
boltzmann machine which can help you in
terms of building your recommendation
system or it could be a reinforcement
learning algorithm which will help you
in terms of building some robust trial
and error kind of application that we
want to
then once this part is done now
eventually you will have a Capstone
project now this Capstone project is
very comprehensive and it tests your
understanding on all these components
that you have covered right from python
for data science still Advanced deep
learning or deep learning so it will it
will be covering uh data wrangling data
preprocessing cleaning part
transformation feature engine link then
the algorithm selection what kind of
algorithm you are building fine tuning
it and and all that aspect will be
covered in Capstone so that is a very
very comprehensive project which will
test you on the entire program
now in addition to that you have some
electives also one of them is use case
of charge GPT so chart GPT if you see
over the uh in last few months have have
raised to a different level altogether
so we so here we talk about use cases of
charge GPT simple prompts how you do it
so basically a overview of prompt
engineering how chart GPT uh will be
will take up prompt and it will give you
the right outcome that you are looking
so in general conversational uh AI uh
and chat jpt is what we talk about there
which is a very interesting elective
actually these uh an in current time and
and day then we you also have NLP and
speech recognition where you get to
learn how to work with the text Data how
do you do a speech recognition which is
again very interesting part then you
have a little more uh comprehensive
program on reinforcement learning
however it will be introduced to you in
advanced deep learning but reinforcement
learning in particular talks about
different kind of Frameworks which you
can use within a reinforcement learning
part and then you are also introduced to
get a git and GitHub training which is a
very important Concept in terms of when
you're when you're collaborating on a
project with different people so GitHub
is pretty useful so that is also is as a
part of elective then you have master
classes from Purdue team where uh you
will have some uh someone coming and
sharing their own knowledge uh and and
giving you a certain do's and don'ts
which is very useful and eventually you
also have industry master class which I
mentioned earlier also which was some
some industry experts come and each one
have been involved in a different
industry different kind of problem so
that becomes very useful if you listen
to them it gives you a lot of idea that
in a real-time scenario what kind of
challenges challenges comes up and then
how do they solve so that's pretty
useful that's an entire program that
that we have here thank you and I want
to point out about the electives that
they're included in the cost of the
program so you you have the option as a
learner to take uh any or or all of them
as see fit based on your interest and
your time availability so that's a good
way to add
and more flavor in depth to the program
by customizing it through the electives
um
so
people in the program learn
um when we say you learn these tools and
platforms that means they're actually
using them in projects and case studies
that
how does that kind of play out in the
program
now that's kind of actually what happens
is if you look at the entire project
life cycle of a machine learning
algorithm at different level different
requirements are there so I might need
some data visualization to be done so
that I understand that data in a better
manner before I move to the data
analysis part so matplotlib come into
the picture which will help in terms of
visualizing the data or probably I'm
working I have already finished working
on a particular project and I want to
deploy it so then python itself has a
framework called flask which will help
you in terms of deploying the
algorithm so these tools which are
mentioned over here will come very handy
at different stages of machine learning
uh Project Life Cycle that you talk
about so so I might use Django I might
use kiras I might use tensorflow SQL for
machine learning that's how it goes so
these are these are these are the ones
which will be uh taught to you some of
them will be taught to you some of them
will be given overview that's how it
goes so that you understand each one of
them in entirely and then we will be
using in in in in some of the problem as
well yeah so you get actual hands-on
experience with them as you use them on
the labs and projects so that's
extremely helpful and you you'll have
examples then
to be able to show how you use these and
then as we mentioned several times the
Capstone project which kind of
culminates the program
the learner can choose from several
different industry domains the problem
the industry aligned problem that suits
them best or interests them most is that
how that works
uh they have multiple options and from
there we can they can choose and it it
covers different domains actually and uh
it might have a manifest from
manufacturing probably from image
detection it might be uh coming from uh
from uh e-commerce where they want to
build yeah they want to build a
recommendation engine the different
domains that is that is that that are
covered over there uh and and you're
talking about Capstone and not only not
not to forget they will also have uh
lesson end projects which will be part
of every section that they are covering
so right from a python for data science
and then move to the advanced deep
learning each section will have their
own project as well which will be coming
from different Industries so it gives
you a very uh comprehensive knowledge on
on different types of problem which
which exist and how to solve them
thank you and again once you finish the
Capstone project and that's evaluated
for credit
that is how you've finally earned your
your certificate for the program and
there's a number of examples of the
kinds of
you know industry aligned problems that
you might work on either in the Capstone
or a long way along the way in the
project
uh horsehand projects so
you for example customer service
requests
um
right simulate handling complaints
through the 311 call service from New
York City
might look at different
book rental recommendations or
recommendation system
might look at feature engineering
meaning what what are the things that
are most important in this particular
case in a real estate transaction to
home buyers
kind of assigning value to each of those
different home features
facial recognition
health care and one of the most
important aspects of ML and AI today is
using healthcare for Diagnostics and
recognizing patterns that doctors might
find difficult to see or Radiologists
might find difficult to see so here's an
example of looking at data about
heart health and predicting who's going
to have a heart attack or looking at how
to detect lung infection from the
pattern of symptoms and images so
this is these are examples of kind of
real world type problems that you'd work
on in the program
and
so the simply learned
delivery aspect takes us through
um
kind of an ecosystem of support for you
as the learner
we assign a program manager to work with
Purdue and make sure that we're
delivering the program
their standards and getting their master
classes set up we also assign a cohort
manager so when you enroll you're going
to go through this program step by step
with the other people who enroll on the
same day
um basically people are going to be on a
similar Pace right I mean
yeah there would be on a similar Pace we
make sure that everyone comes from the
same level of understanding and then we
take them forward
and of course your instructors in each
course are going to be helping you
succeed in that course but you also be
able to to draw on support from your
fellow students
classroom interactions but also your
uh community bulletin board system that
allows you to interact with people
outside of classes and finally the the
curriculum and the other resources the
e-books pre-recorded videos study
materials all of that type of thing are
available to help you succeed as well so
this is said it's an ecosystem of
support designed to help you um maximize
your chance of success
so I mean if you would like to take us
through if you have available of the
learning management system can you show
us how this works
yeah
so I will stop sharing my screen and you
should be able to share yours
okay so uh once you enroll for a for the
program you will be given uh access to
our LMS once you log into your LMS you
get the
you get the postgraduate program and Ain
and ml
which is listed over here and then
you can click on the program
and this is the best part about this LMS
is that first of all it tells you what's
your
what's your
basically how you're doing actually at
the moment so if you look at me two
percent of learning has been completed
for me is what it's saying so it keeps
track of how the sessions are going for
you and it also tells you that when
you'll be able to unlock your
certificate so it keeps track of your
learning entirely and then all the
programs that we have mentioned uh just
a little while ago is given over here so
first is your induction which is given
over here
and then all other programs as well if
you see all the sections which we have
covered which we have spoken about is
given over here python for data science
data science with python machine
learning deep learning Advanced deep
learning and then your electives that I
was talking about
so what it does now I suppose uh I have
finished or if I'm showing any of the
program like if I go to machine learning
I click on this
and what it does it gives you everything
that you need under a single section
over here so first of all here you get a
self learning videos which will be
helpful for you to get some
understanding prior to the class so
these these self learning videos are
available for you on each of the topic
even though that topic will be covered
in the classroom it gives you some
understanding on it so that you come
little prepared which is very useful
actually so you can click on this and
you can go and check what is inside it
you can understand through a video that
what this topic is all about or any
other topic for that matters it gives
you overview of all those topics those
are self learning videos some of the
sessions you will have certain self
learning videos which will be mandatory
as well it might be
so that's that's what you get then you
have an option of live class you click
on that your classes will be available
here itself so uh whenever it is due you
can come to your my my classes click on
your classes and then you can join from
here itself the other good thing is once
the class is over and the recordings are
available recordings can be accessed
from my classes option itself so your
recordings will also be listed over here
you can click and you can watch them
whenever you want so in case if you
missed out something or probably you
want to just go back and re-watch it so
that you can get the thorough
understanding of it you can do that here
itself
then
it also has
the reference materials which will be
used in the classroom
the reference materials that will be
used in the classroom that could be a
trainer PPT it could be some code books
so all that you can download it from
here
and also the data sets which will be
used in the classroom so you don't have
to actually go to any other place to get
your code book or the ppts or even data
sets everything is there under one
single screen so just download keep it
handy whenever the session is going on
you will be using it it also gives you a
lab guide so that you get well
equipped with the understanding of the
lab also then
you have your practice lab option
so the practice lab in and that's what
Stuart was mentioning that in case we
want to
we want to uh
do the experimentation with any kind of
algorithm we want to run and we want to
see how it's working out so the lab is
also built in here you go to your lab
and it looks like this you will have
your code book over here which is
generally shared in advance
and you get to you get to Simply log
into your LMS go to the practice lab and
start coding you don't have to install
anything on your system this lab is
is
it comes with the pre-installed
libraries so you don't have to worry
about that one of the library is not
installed on your system or probably not
compatible with your system everything
is there just start using it now how it
works in the live virtual class just to
give a little perspective here like if
I'm teaching here time series modeling
so we'll start I'll give you the
understanding that how it works so here
itself I'll explain you entirely so this
is just the agenda which is we are
setting it up and then what we do is
I'll go down and I'll tell you what is
time series I'll explain you all the
parts and then we'll take up a data set
now when I'm saying stock price data set
where do I get it it's there in our data
set folder which I told you that you can
download and keep it the data is there
and then straight away we start
implementing the concept
okay and explain you how while while
while implementing that concept some
more
some more
aspects of aspects of the algorithm will
be covered which will be explained to
you that why we are doing something and
what kind of
inference you can draw from that like if
I did some some charting what are the
insights from the chart why are we using
a particular box plot and then
eventually we'll Implement everything
and we'll show you the result and will
tell you what this result is all about
and how do you
how do you then save it and if you have
to re reuse it then how will you do it
so this entire part will be covered in
the session itself
so and and and if any kind of changes
are are being done in the code suppose
something you asked about that can we do
something like this or something like
that so if I'm writing some extra lines
over here like suppose like this I can
after the session I can share this file
on the community
so that's another feature of our LMS
what happens over there is we also have
a community over here see this
so on the LMS you have Community option
here now this community is a is a place
where you can interact with the with
your with your peers and you can also
interact with the trainer uh uh like
suppose you are having session on the
weekends and during the weekdays when
you are going through certain concept
you need some help you can connect to
the community you can post your
questions your doubts and we will be
there to clarify it
so that's what community does you also
have option of creating your notes for
every session that you are doing and you
can simply download them then if suppose
uh somewhere in between you get stuck
with some problem in the in the LMS
probably it doesn't happen generally but
I'm just saying or you need some some
technical help there is a help option
also available which is available 24x7
you can click on that you can raise a
ticket and then we will help you out in
terms of sorting out your issues
so that's your lab that we are talking
about in addition to that lab
you also have your assessment tab here
which is there for for every section so
it's not a Capstone but this is
basically for a particular section that
you have completed a course then you
have a project over here and if you see
this is what we were talking about that
these projects come from different
Industries so this is a Mercedes bench
manufacturing project similarly building
a recommendation engine or it could be
income qualification you need to
understand from for for World Banks so
if they come from different Industries
so it gives you a lot of understanding
that what kind of problem we are solving
uh when it comes to different Industries
different sectors different domains
that's why it's very helpful
so you solve one of them that's a
requirement for your for you to complete
and then only the certificate be
unlocked but generally what I always
suggest is that once you solve and
submit but others also you can just see
what's happening inside it
then once you finish this submit your
project and once you clear it your
certificate will be unlocked
so that's what your LMS is all about
quite comprehensive everything is under
one one one uh
platform you don't have to jump from one
place to another and it's fully
integrated with the lab also that's how
it works
thank you
I think that's a pretty
uh in-depth overview of how the LMS
works and
that should give people confidence that
this is a platform
that they can use uh you know fairly
straightforward way to to manage all of
their classes manage all of their
projects do all of the of the work and
get real examples and then
as you're doing the examples as you're
doing the projects those are being
logged into your git portfolio so you've
got you'll end up with a kind of set of
examples of experience right
that's correct okay super so I'm gonna
go ahead
and return to our
presentation a little bit
and as it comes up
foreign
there we go
so the professor at uh Purdue who
oversees this program is
Nicola and he coordinates with us makes
sure that we are delivering to um their
standards and also coordinates providing
the
Purdue faculty to come and do the master
classes
and so
this is your assurance that what you're
learning in this program
is backed by the reputation and the
um all faith and credit so to speak of
Purdue University
and you can see here a number of
different instructors from different
backgrounds
um
Rocky nihil Newton Simon of course
Indra uh I'm a team and uh you can see
that each of them has extensive industry
background
um so that you're learning not just from
academic theoretical background people
but you're also learning from people who
have done this kind of work in the real
world for real industry clients and or
employers and this uh gives you
background for learning how this
set of skills will be applied in a
practical sense in the real world
so these are your colleagues in the
program
you um
add anything to that
yeah there's uh our uh they're my
colleague in terms of handling these uh
these programs and each one of them if
you see a vast amount of experience and
they all are pretty well equipped with
the with the right knowledge and they
teach you with the Hands-On uh delivery
that's how it goes that's just to add it
yeah thank you
so let's talk a little bit about learner
outcomes and and
this is one of the interesting aspects
of the program is the postgraduate
program
you encourage people to to join while
they are working professionals it's
designed to support working
professionals that means you're going to
be learning alongside people who are
working in various companies
who are examples of people that have
taken this kind of I've taken this
program in the past so people come into
the program working for a number of
different Industries not just
information technology or software but
also manufacturing Healthcare Pharma
Banking and Financial Services really
around
um
all of the different potential industry
segments how does that play out in the
classroom
there are a lot of you know kind of
actually uh honestly telling you that is
pretty uh beneficial to the to the to
the uh participants in a in a manner
that when when we teach a particular
concept
somebody comes from manufacturing they
correlate with their job role that you
know I can use this concept in in
solving this particular problem and this
share so someone coming from
manufacturing they give an example this
is what I can use and then somebody
coming from banking they started
explaining that how this particular
concept will be useful for them so what
happens is the kind of knowledge gets
shared is is is is is enormous and and
that way uh we learn from from from from
each one of them uh other than that the
program is such just to tell you that
they might come from a different
background but the program is such that
we align them towards us to the same
objective and make sure that we are
aligned to that throughout the course
but as I mentioned it is pretty useful
when people come from different
background in terms of domain expertise
experience they share their own
understanding their knowledge they ask
questions which is related to their job
workflow the work that they are doing
and and when we start discussing all
this this gives you a lot of
understanding that okay the same concept
I can use in banking also probably in HR
also probably in telecommunication as
well which is pretty interesting
so that's a great way to kind of Network
and and also build out your kind of
well-rounded background as a
professional in the industry of learning
from other people who are working there
and here are some people who have
completed the program
and
they've done very well the uh
all have really good things to say about
the program
and the way that it gives you hands-on
experience teaches you about
programming methods the mathematics in
deep learning so we hope that we can add
you to this kind of roster you'll see a
number more of additional
testimonials from Learners on our web
page and I'll share that link
minutes
so we had a question about
um
job placement and simply learn offers
career assist service is not a job
placement service
but this is for learners
India and the United States and
it gives you access to a job board this
is
something that extends for six months
after you complete your certificate so
once you're awarded your certificate you
have six months to use these Services uh
again the exclusive job portal
you're in India or in the US
um
the resume review and rewrite service
which allows you to work with a writer
and do a couple of new drafts of your
resume to adapt it to
um the world of automated tracking
systems and AI Bots and still make it
look good to people who will see it when
it lands on their desk and then the
one-on-one interview prep service which
gives you the opportunity to live
one-on-one interview
um simulations for the things that you
might have to deal with in phone screen
interviews or technical skills
interviews or
corporate fit cultural fit interviews
and so all of these services are
available to you for those six months to
help you with your job search again we
don't have a job placement or job
guarantee program here
but these are services that will help
sharpen your
job search and maximize your chance of
success there
So based on what we've shared with you
and I um
so far
are you interested in
joining this program
I'll leave this open for about 15
seconds
[Music]
and about three quarters of our audience
are interested in joining the program
which is great I will share with you
then so
first we want to cover the cost of the
program
and we're showing this in U.S and India
denominations if you're elsewhere in the
world the course is of course available
to you and you'll want to look at our
web page or contact uh ask us at
simplylearn.net and ask about the cost
and how it's denominated in your country
in the US it's 4 500 which can be
financed at 397 a month
um in India it's one lock forty nine
thousand nine hundred ninety nine which
can be financed DMI basis for 5105 rupee
a month and if you have an employer who
offers the benefit of tuition
reimbursement you should ask them about
that and see if you can get them to help
defray the cost of the program
always a benefit worth exploring and
that would be the policy of your current
employer so
you can contact us again and ask us at
simplylearn.net to find out about costs
and other locations
and the enrollment steps are starting by
emailing us at ask us at simplylearn.net
the next session
starts with classes on July 31st so you
can actually
take the induction session tomorrow July
13th although there will be another
induction session after that before July
31st but this is uh the next available
cohort if you join
I can take two things one is that we
will offer you a bonus discount you want
to ask us at simplylearn.net what that
discount is and we'll share that with
you that's available if you join this
July cohort and we urge you to hurry
because we limit the number of seats in
any given cohort so that the instructors
have time to work with each student
so there's not an unlimited number of
places in the cohort we try to limit it
to about 30 so that instructors have
time
deal with a reasonable class size
if you're interested it makes sense for
you to contact us right away they'll ask
you about your background or aptitude
for Math and programming and if you
qualify they'll send you an admission
letter
and
that
if you're interested in joining how soon
would you want to join are you looking
at the July cohort or are you looking
August September
or maybe further down the road
so I'll leave this one open for about 20
seconds total
I'll close this
and five four
three
two one
so about uh forty percent a little more
than 40 percent of people want to join
either into July or August September
those of you looking further down the
road please contact us at ask us at
simplylearn.net and we'll keep it keep
you in touch with regard to Future
cohorts answer any questions you have
for those of you who are interested in
joining right away
please contact us at ask us
simplywin.net and we'll get you started
and
let me
now we'll take the questions and answers
I'm going to
stop the sharing here
and we have lots of questions I mean um
so
the first couple have to do with the
cost we've done that you will get a link
to the recording
talked about the bathmatics background
uh we have a question from Kearney who
says I'm an electronic engineer so how
can Ai and ml be helpful for me
so electronic Engineers basically a lot
of embedded systems which are getting
built these days how we are we are we're
actually adding the AI component to it
and uh
and and uh if you talk about smart
devices you talk about uh automations
that are getting done a lot of scope is
there to create intelligence around that
and then build applications will will
build tools which will be utilizing that
so basically I'm just trying to tell you
that Electronics is not something that
uh you are thinking that it will not be
useful later on a lot of tools and
applications are getting built around
around embedded system which utilizes uh
AI yeah my original training was in
electrical engineering and circuit
design and
back then you would have to do a lot of
manual calculation to determine you know
whether you had sufficient current flow
throughout a circuit or where the
leakages would be today you have AIML
tools that can help you lay out an
entire you know
massive scale integrated circuit system
so
the more you know the AI and ml is
applicable both for applications for
design for every aspect of electronics
even automate the process of circuit
design layout optimization is their
performance analysis or probably in the
signal processing it could enhance the
audio signals or probably image
processing is speech recognition all
this is kind of there's a overlap when
you talk about all these aspects yep
absolutely
um
we had a question from himanshi about
how to become a professional coder uh
that would be a different program that's
available and you can ask us simply
on.net about those kinds of programs the
focus of this program is to become
uh AIML practitioner
um bumsy asked if you could kind of give
a thumbnail difference between the data
analysts and data engineer roles
sure so in a very simple fashion if I
have to tell you data analyst focuses on
analyzing that data and come up with
some actionable insights uh data
ingenious will be working a little more
on the infrastructure side in terms of
building the data pipelines making sure
that data is integrated with different
analytical
layers which are there so that's that's
what the main difference would be
uh
uh cut elix okay uh he has a question
about how to remove bias from algorithms
and also uh
you could comment on how much data you
need to build a robust
machine learning model
biases uh what we do is once we build
any model as part of your ml Ops would
be uh uh uh one part would be where
you'll be understanding what kind of
biases exist in the models you'll be
going at the different level of data and
try and understand uh what are the
issues and then for every every day
every bias or every every issue that you
find now then you try to understand how
we can solve it sometimes what happens
is like I'm doing classification and my
model is biased towards one of the class
so then we add more data to another
classes and it works well so different
uh scenario will have a different way of
handling it but that's how generally it
works so biases will be taken care by
that what was the second part of the
question
second part of the question is uh
the way they phrased it how much of
business do you need to gather in terms
of banking Insurance processing from
shop to shop my interpretation forgive
me if I'm wrong is um you know how do
you build up
data models that can apply across you
know different business entities
so if you're looking at building a
banking application how do you make sure
that it's not just
applicable to your bank
um see it becomes very difficult in
certain areas to build generic product
because of the kind of data you are
capturing uh One Bank might have a
different way of capturing data points
to another so it becomes a little
difficult but there are certain areas
where all the banks will be or any
financial institution institution will
be captioning exactly same field same
data because of the regulatory
requirement so on those sorts of
scenarios you can build some generic uh
uh algorithmic application and that's
how these crate rating and all the work
also they have a generic model which
works on any of the bank so it depends
on the scenario
thank you um
we had a question about calculating
macros in Excel that would again be a
different course on data anal for data
analysts rather than for AIML but again
you can ask us about that
um
what days are the live classes and time
so those are in the weekends what what
time of day are usually the the
glasses Cheryl would like to know
uh generally it would be on weekends and
uh weekends four hours on Saturday four
hours on Sunday that's how it goes
what what time on the uh of time of day
time we have I think we have two batches
one runs in the evening one runs in the
morning
right and that's because it's a
worldwide program so it has to be yeah
uh something that the people from
different time zones can access
um
log on
so he's covered a number of uh
Concepts through through self-study and
experience of clustering data mining
decision trees neural networks uh
Tableau visualization uh has not
received a certificate in these how
would he be able to show this off
to employers and demonstrate that he has
these skills
what would you suggest for somebody
um to create
something to show to employers
um say uh eventually you'll have to
Showcase in terms of what you have done
in the past what kind of project you
have worked upon and also uh generally
what happens if you're able to uh
express your knowledge in a right manner
on the on in the interviews uh uh
sometimes I'm just saying that uh they
they they focus more on your
understanding rather than what you have
done in the past so that's how it how it
goes so if you are able to do both the
aspects like you have done some work and
also you're able to you're pretty good
in terms of explaining things uh there
shouldn't be a problem yeah
one of the things that that we try to
address in the design of these programs
with Purdue and
our other programs is that
you want to build that portfolio of
examples so
um if you had taken this program or if
you wanted to take this or a similar
program with us you would build a
portfolio but if you've already done
this type of work and you want it
you know work on projects and build a
portfolio or as I mean said if you have
a good talking game then that should
help you
um
is there a exception to the ba
requirement uh you really have to ask us
at simpleline.net about your particular
situation if you're about to receive
your bachelor's if you're in your last
year of your bachelor's program and it
will be awarded to you before you finish
this program that's uh that's acceptable
um they don't really make too many other
exceptions because they do want to make
sure that
have a certain Baseline of the students
who are joining the program
um is there a limit to the number of
electives one can take no you can take
as many as fit into your schedule and as
interest you so you don't have to take a
minimum number of electives and there is
no maximum
um
talked about placement guarantee so
again not a placement guarantee from
this program just the placement of the
job assist for helping you with your job
search
um
so we have a question from olanka who
has taken other simple learning courses
that have covered some of the similar
topics would they be able to test out of
some of these courses and then just
focus on the additional topics I don't
know the answer to that I'm not sure I
mean does but I would refer you to ask
us at simplylearn.net to ask about that
particular situation
and um
they'll be the best ones to handle that
for you how important work asks how
important is it to know SQL and database
Administration
within the context of data science and
AIML
uh it would be a pretty useful added
Advantage I would say because uh
sometimes what happens when we are
working on a particular problem I'll
tell you it happens a lot with my my
firm we go to the client and we say okay
this is the kind of problem we can solve
for you and they say okay this is the
data we have and they expose their their
DBS that that they are having and then
we need to connect to their database and
then pull data and then start working on
it so generally we use Python for the
same but we might have to fire some SQL
queries from python itself to pull the
data or probably lose some work in the
databases it will always be helpful if
you know those uh basic routines how to
write them and that will be sufficient
and if you go deeper into that direction
of the the topic that's going into Data
engineering and where you might if
people who want who find that kind of
thing fascinating and specialize in that
work on the the infrastructure and the
pipelines for the data to
these things so that's another career
path that's within the general overview
um are there good public groups to join
who are developing interests in AIML
doing things like uh open source
projects things like that can you
recommend any of those
I think kaggle is pretty good for that
yeah
it's pretty nice okay
um we had a question about what
operating system and laptop requirements
are required basically this is all done
through your web browser so if your web
browser runs quickly and your um
your internet connection is good you
have high bandwidth you won't have a
problem you don't have to have a
particular Windows operating system you
can do it on a Mac so
all that is available to you
is that is that accurate
that's correct and there's no
requirement as such that you have to
have gpus and all okay
um and that's one of the great things
about this program is that the the
Computing infrastructure for you is
provided on a virtual basis so that you
go into that Jupiter lab you can do the
work and not have to
best in building an advanced Hardware
platform of your own
um
see
we have someone uh Sephora who says that
they have uh bachelor's in accounting
and how would Ai and ml be useful in
that field
uh AI accounting when you talk about
basically you're talking about financial
transactions anyway so so starting with
the basic automation that you can do you
can any kind of time consuming uh
repetitive accounting tasks are there it
could be as simple as data and it could
be invoice processing that you do or
reconciliations those could be automated
easily with the summit certain
algorithms you can do data analysis
large volume of financial data you can
quickly and accurately analyze and
understand them you can do fraud
detection if you want uh based on the
accounting data you can build uh you can
make some predictions based on the
historical data assisting in financial
forecasting budgeting cash flow
management or it could be audit and
compliance that you're talking about so
a lot of things you can do you can use
NLP to understand what's been told what
has been given in a in a particular
email letter whatever you have received
and analyze it and understand a client
in a better manner so all that you can
do and if you're looking to move Beyond
accounting into other aspects of
financial services for example Ai and ml
is the basis for things like fintech
where
the new apps that provide micro credit
or instant credit decisions are all
based on
Ai and ml algorithms
um and the last question we have in the
Q a before I go back to the chat is what
type of machine learning or deep
learning algorithms
are most used in industry these days
is there a real answer to that or is it
everything I wouldn't be able to answer
that in a sense that uh I might as a as
a e-commerce website I might use uh
probably a boltzmann machine to build
recommendation system another one
another company might use a simple item
based approach and both will work
properly because they have different
kind of data so there's no right answer
to it
all right and um
I think that covers pretty much all the
questions we have because well that's
all the time we have for questions so I
am going to um close out
our
presentation today
just wanted to thank
I want to thank you Amit for
being with us
being
generous with your time and your
attention I'm going to ask one last
question
for those of you in the audience who are
interested in enrolling would you like
us to contact you
directly
leave this open for about five seconds
close the poll
just under half of you said yes so you
can expect a call from
our folks
our learning consultants and
as I promised I'm going to put into the
chat window the link to our program page
so you can
either email us at the
email address that we've talked about
that's in the chat or else you can go to
the program page you'll be able to
contact us through that
as well
and
with that
I'm going to
close out the program
and again thank you Amit for your time
and for your attention
I really appreciate that
and
we want to thank everyone who made time
wherever you are in the world whether
it's evening or morning
uh for taking your time to invest in
this webinar and learning about how you
can make a future in Ai and ml for
yourself
you can use the QR code to get to our
webpage or the link in the chat and we
look forward to welcoming you into the
Purdue simply learn learning community
so with that that concludes our webinar
for today
thank you so much